carrara quanto ci metti di aprirla bella
tutti ragazzi e benvenuto che sono video
sono dj ed oggi siamo sulla demo ragazzi
che è uscita di pokémon soleluna devo
ricominciare ragazzi poteva lanciare un
contest scaricate la demo di pokémon
soleluna questa che sto per fare io in
questo video fatevi un self impostatelo
su instagram col hashtag soleluna perchè
scrivete nella descrizione perché
preferireste pokémon sole oppure per chi
preferireste pokémon l'uno quale dei due
preferite in modo divertente da nintendo
alla fine sceglierà un vincitore al
quale verrà dato unit endo 3ds
l'edizione quella fatta per sole e luna
che dovrebbe essere una cosa troppo
figlia io ho una copia del gioco potevo
al sole o pokémon luna la scelta
ovviamente va al vincitore mi lascia
comunque ragazzi il link del regolamento
nella descrizione così almeno chi vuole
partecipare se lo legge in tutta
tranquillità quindi postate le foto su
instagram che poi me ne vado pure a
vedere io quindi sarà una roba troppo
[ __ ] io comincio perché sto aspettando
state moda una vita e mezza scusatemi
che lingua e giocare il dov'è il coreano
va bene facciamo italiano inizio gioco
camera inizia il gioco fa mi potere e
vabbè addirittura con lo zoom
ai miei tempi con pokémon non si vedeva
vanko il pixel di dovere di restare alla
città l'iniziale va beh
ma veramente è diventato così figo
pokemon negli anni una lettera caro sun
no io sono fra i j prove stai leggendo
questa lettera vuol dire che se già
arrivato a da lola è quello della lola
come va con il greening già che ho
lasciato per tempo camera ma il caldo e
scommetto che non vedo l'ora di
scatenarsi in lotte infuocate nel tepore
della regione dia lola il mittente non
ha scritto da nessuna parte la lettera
non è firmata va bene deve essere un
tipo distratto ed tipo m file catturare
la lettera arriva la zia sun
dobbiamo anche come brutto è sola
dobbiamo andare in comune bisogna
registrare il cambio di residenza ma non
le puoi fare tu queste cose non ci
voglio a ugo ii zona tela va beh ma
quanto figo in zona commerciale c'è un
mash up
ciao zio fratello è registrato ma perché
devo farle io queste cose burocratiche
non puoi farle tusann sapevi che allora
non è solo il nome della regione ma
anche il saluto che ci si scambia ma
cosa quindi in realtà milano si dovrebbe
chiamare bella zio allora facciamo
minuti registrerà il cambio residenza a
lola ma come vestito strozzino sbrigano
le pratiche necessarie nel frattempo
accumulate di pune in sala d'attesa vi
chiamerò quando sarà tutto pronto
va bene d'accordo grazie come com'è che
parte diversamente da tutti gli altri
pokémon che ho visto fino adesso temo
che ci sarà da aspettare ancora un po
posso già muovermi non ero pronta a
questa ondata di emozioni fermi esce
dare un'occhiata qua fuori e vedere che
resterà a bocca aperta
va bene giorno perché si color beige
book
ciao a te fratello a know how e il nome
ehi ciao tu sei san vero esami stalker
il sì e tu chi sei brutto stop per
schifoso
io sono a un piacere ciao ammalò la
mauch addio a questa mia madre
vedo che ti stai già facendo degli amici
io sono found lei e la mamma di san vero
piacere come fai sapere tutte queste
cose perchè non fate un giro in città
no no mamma non mi lasciare con questo
qua mentre io aspetto che le pratiche
siano pronte no mamma non mi lasciare
con questi individui che è un'idea
grandiosa dai sun mandiamo ti faccio
vedere la città siccome sono contento
che mi fai da guida mammari
trasferiamoci veloce ma il divertimento
contro nuovo amico e si va bene lo
sapevo io pure sparita mia madre va bene
vorrei ragazzi pazienza proviamoci
spero che almeno come guida non sia una
persona scadente guarda una faccia nuova
ciao bello si dice bella zio comunque
non segnalò la vero fratello richiesta
gente
cos'è sta roba sono dei gangster abrate
come stiamo qui sono sicura il team sky
questi mascalzoni vanno in giro a rubare
prova ci prova ma come ti permetti
non siamo dei ladri sono solo un gruppo
di burloni con la passione per i pokémon
degli altri degli altri era nascosto
ovviamente non gli avete mai questi può
che mostrino ma io non ce l'ho ai
blocchi monte non ho ancora preso lo
star ferma col se è questo che volete
allora ve lo chiederemo meno gentilmente
per lo state facendo
guarda che non siete dei figli se fate
dei gesti da mongoloidi arner anche tu
hai dei pokémon vero allora preparati a
lottare non ho il pokémon i di zio non
ho scelto lo start e va bene in scala
ragazzi prima partita di oggi parte la
sfida di record le grandi si rifiuta
ieri recluta tim scale manda in campo io
non ho letto il nome chi è questo qua ha
già è vero ciò che mi lavo letto
all'inizio ciò alzheimer gray ninja non
è assolutamente il mio start del mio
starter è quello di fuoco perché io sono
un tipo ott
va bene sembra tipo una versione di zig
zag un un po modificato c'è un po giusto
da donald trump tra l'altro colpi
inflitti due lo young rose non ha
evergreening al 36 cioè non vuoi mettere
sun ha vinto dell'ottocento pounds thank
you very much and brothers
come fa a essere così forte questo qui
questo qui che sotto fratello aspettate
che la nostra capano sappia non avete
scampo dinanzi alla sua rabbia ma non
sapete che pare smette da dire pare
sfumata di mongoloidi con i pokemon al
proprio fianco non c'è nulla aveva già
facciamo già graining al 36 pure vieni
andiamo a far rimettere in sesto le
nostre squadre così ti faccio vedere
tutto il centro pokémon
va bene il bello si muove si muove a zig
zag e un tizio ma va ragazzi usciamo ha
provato andare via via via via ponte
bella la canzone regali hi sun questo
centro pokemon sì lo vedo lo vedo
tranquillo
fatemi entrare per vedere come non so se
l'hanno rinnovato ragazzi non ho visto
screen
direi di sì se parli con la signorina al
banco rimettere in sesto il fuoco non si
lo so gioco a pokemon da quando sono
nato da una super porzione grazie
quanto è gentile sto tizio fammi pensare
dove possiamo andare adesso ma io ho un
paio di the cell avrei addio
mica starbucks salve ne sta occupando
della caffetteria mentre proprietario e
via ma che storia il market ma come
chiuso stiamo aspettando le nuove scorte
va bene dove possiamo andare adesso non
lo so allora faccio io vado in giro è la
rimani 49 di casey è uscito chi è questo
poi la chi è il tuo amico a professor cu
cui il professore dei pokémon della
regione dia lola si chiama cui è la moda
è un palestrato regali e tutto figo
ciao sun sono cui poco fa quelli del
team scalciano saliti ce la siamo cavata
ma non è stato facile ma cosa in un
attacco alla rocca po tutti quanti
potresti affrontare una prova per
diventare più forte che ne dici sanno va
bene
facciamo così quando sei pronto per
affrontare la prova vieni alla collina
10 carati ti aspetterò l'iva va bene
ciao si è stati dove di quel signore ti
accompagnerà la collina riciclarte
quindi devo andare dal tizio va bene
adesso ci vado fatemi fare un giro un
attimino la prima comunque vado ci sono
gli slot hoc che problemi
fatevi passare che poi tra l'altro io ci
passerei tranquillamente in mezzo ma va
bene non importa mi fate passare che
succede
hai visto molti se lo posso vedere dai
volevo andare in giro maledizione
neanche quel maina gioia siamo era
perfetto ciao zio non è per farmi gli
affari tuoi ma non è che per caso
vorresti andare alla collina 10 carati
se fai bene a farti gli affari miei
bene ma che poi non ci potrà arrivare da
solo a napoli ci laviamo mi chiama che
sfiga ma neanche un passo fatto è
apparso un piggy back cosa voglio di chi
ti salva di molte tra patch notes tv che
anche sferza
se non lo shock con molti si pensa a me
ne vado con questo uno scarso e abbiamo
bisogno di essere allenato dal dottor
cui peso non faccio due passi
that's why bay bay questo canale natrice
cosa se quando gli sguardi si incrociano
parte alla sfida grazie non lo sapevo
ma no è quella un allenatore non sta
solo dicendo guarda come mi aspetta con
la si è alzato alle 6 del mattino per
andar lì ad aspettarmi lo so io volevi
battermi zio aveva un bambino poverino
senti un po ce l'hai un po che non vero
ma potrebbe parte la sfida di dario
sembra dario moccia dario marmocchio
perché dario marmocchio manda in campo
rochus tre ninja versus rochus scusa
narro crufts so manco legge i nomi
sembra un groove height versione troppo
carina facciamo aree assalto
e l'amato quanta rabbia stai tranquillo
sola meta vita elevato perfect ciao zio
è stato bello questo per efficaci che ho
più fitti un normografo rapida ai
sconfitto dario marmocchio guarda come
preoccupato e deve sborsare il grano ho
perso ma è stato divertente ho vinto 560
yammer il luogo della pro am a non sono
niente perché non sono più giappone
allora no niente ho sbagliato
no ti prego non c'è un banco fune di
fuga c'è un pikachu perché c'è un
piccato cui adesso vi spiego come
funziona la prova 4 pokémon alla collina
10 carati si nascondono 4 pokémon 2
django o e due a chiamo o per superare
la mia prova dovrai fotografarli tutti
con fotografarla family catturare zio
prendi questo poche misure di severa per
fare le foto
ma non posso catturarli che faccio prima
il mio piccolo è piuttosto forte si si
si vede non ha niente da invidiare al
tigre niger grazie al pene fulmine
contro acqua grazie che non invidio
picchiata nella prova bene o anche
pikachu ragazzi co2 pokémon superpower
inizia la prova maps out deve esserci un
pokémon nei paraggi poi arrivare in
poche visore sì ma veramente io posso
vedere i pokémon che ho intorno
ma che storia fatta fatta
era quello il poco entusiasmo o ma come
si pronuncia stone o meno si è
spaventato e ti attacca secondo deve
stare calmo perché io ho fatto una prova
che sono paparazzo però stai calma c'è
un cuore giallo in testa lo dedico alle
più belle fanciulle questo pokémon
capito che ninja vediamo secco non
efficace come mia foto
è invece è perfetto non potevo catturare
perché non mi date le poche ball
maledizioni come che faccio ho deciso
che se vai ormai sono skillato lega l'ho
preso giacomo si è spaventato e ti
attacca va bene non fa niente con i miss
guardo
la difesa di graining ma cosa vuoi
sperare di farmi fuori
questo che cosa ma ha diminuito a fare
la difesa spiega c'è nella massa b
l'utile della vita lasciando solo
mancato preso facciamo o ma è
l'evoluzione acamo perché non credo sia
el'evoluzione per forza quanto è grosso
secondo me questo qua faccio fatica a
batterlo regate se lo sciocco veramente
altro falso le mani e mi inchino quanto
forcoli elevato ma li devo pochissimo
regalo a chiamo usa azione è fortissimo
ma ne moltiplica va beh allora non è
efficace niente piuttosto cristiano
forza al santo mi va bene sono né molto
efficace me ne vado è almeno quello
delle ninja riceve mille punti fra yeah
che succede state calmi
cosa sta succedendo permesso no mi son
dimenticato gli usa il pica su lega cioè
non ho capito bene che ha fatto
estroverso quali da una a livello
quarant'anni fa un mazzo così
ma quindi ragazzi io posso fotografare i
pokemon in ge l'ho fatta
madonna mi carica malissimo adesso c'è
ansia
oddio mi sto prendendo malissimo te
cos'è a che livello è sta roba
pokémon dominante a chiamo ok questo è
forte
queste forte 36 che cosa lo chiama un
dominante lista c'è pare al salto sopra
efficace meno male che me lo segna con
del super efficace dovrei riuscire a
batterlo solo con gremita è in teoria
quanto sono forte sgancia pesi ma
veramente così la cittadina è aumenta di
molto
diventa velocissimo chiama un alleato
europee
l'esagerazione ma davvero si vabbè
recavo ma che potevo giocare giu
[Musica]
questo effetto ma lui lui è andato in
teoria adesso aspettiamo l'ok al cane
dell'infamia
e successo oddio orecchie quando sono
diventato badas ok non è molto efficace
o non essendo molto efficace li ho
levato più di metà vita cioè fortissimo
adesso fatemi cambiare mettere pikachu
solo per provarlo perfetto fi fulmine
fulmine controllo kraft spaccano tutto
paniere bene vabbè che ci avrei fatto
anche con greminger posso tornare dal
prof kukoc legami coi come si chiamava
fukui se riuscita a battere il pokémon
dominante devo farti i miei complimenti
grazie e superato la prova ed ecco il
tuo premio il cerchio z il cerchio z
grandissimi cos'è il cerchio z
mi ero accorto di averti dato l'ultima
posizione che avevo così me la sono data
a gambe mi hanno inseguito fino qua
quanta sei stupido e il capo eccoli di
lado battere la capa sicuramente una
[ __ ] ma anche no io sono plumeria
ufficiale del team sky
ora ci penso io va bene puoi usare il
potere z di pikachu fini presente però
che in ogni lotta poi utilizzarlo solo
una volta questa giornata è
particolarmente impegnativa per
l'allenatore number one del mondo ovvero
fa dj parte la sfida di plumeria vai più
mary a famigliari ma un po che non solo
ma come ma coi gol ma cosa pensa di fare
con un gol bat
a meno che non sia il 50 ma che schifo
fi era più forte il pokemon selvatico
ottenuto prima
allora famigliare il potere z così
subito power
giga scarica folgorante va bene potere z
circonda pikachu come un aura pica ciusa
la mossa zg gas carica folgorante
francesco nome va in blackout e la città
intera ragazzi
ciao zia mi dispiace lo show stata però
neanche il posto resistenza va bene
ammette la sconfitta zia non hai fatto
neanche una mossa 4.320 coi soldi
salvataggi in corso ce l'ho fatta regali
è stato semplice però
perché tutti hanno pikachu tranne i miei
ragazzi qual è il problema
ma ci sono anche un sacco di pokémon
delle vecchie generazioni non pensavo
criticato e comunque io preferisco il
pokemon leggendario di pokémon sole è
una preferenza mia poi dovete scegliere
quello che volete però io preferisco
quello da vera gazzoli miei questa era
la demo di pokemon sole di pokémon luna
perdonatemi se ottenuto tipo una cuffia
sola però quando ascolto il con le
cuffie se le metto tutte e due non sento
che lo sto dicendo se non le mettono
sento gioco se ne metto una sembra un
deficiente ma almeno più o meno capisco
che non sto facendo io ai ragazzi che un
come episodio di pokémon sole e pokémon
luna però che partecipiate intanto al
contest
io con grave episodio e cose da ragazzi
se vi è piaciuto al momento è un mi
piace anche la pace di facebook e co
migliore descrizione fini scrive ci
picchiavano prossimo vicolo bella
ragazza